man carries a gun he tends to use it
Danny dead pity I had just ordered a
drink from that man take a job looking
for some man to join then difficult
impossible
how many you got so far you and me
Russia we work for her that's right that
mega murdered in hostage
I want something I take it he will take
everything we have so you seek revenge
I seek righteousness but I'll take
revenge on these long a few help us
fight but what the misfits we are you
know shoot good thing I'll do it
he's local my friend oh good we got a
Mexican since we're bonding
Oh
we got seven he's out army
and they'll be murdered by the world's
greatest lover why are you here hiding
someone else's fight these people
deserve their lives back just make sure
we find the battle in front of us
not a bad one every man's got the right
to choose wait dies we have nowhere else
to go so
what's the point I've always wanted to
blow something it's not a plan
how'd we do and we kill them all
people being driven from our homes
slaughtered in cold blood